bueno puede llegar a ser incluso raúl
que no se llega al final del juicio
puede ocurrir que debido a los problemas
políticos de netania aún no logres
formar gobierno y su partido decida
reemplazarlo por otro líder y por ende
llegue a algún tipo de acuerdo con la
fiscalía y no se concluya sino en una
especie de acuerdo nada más osea ese es
un primer escenario meta no quiere ir
hasta el final porque argumenta que no
hay realmente carne para acusarlo y
sentenciarlo digamos que quería quiere
ir entonces al final para demostrar su
inocencia entonces ahora le pregunto ay
qué manera esto del juicio ha afectado a
netanyahu y al partido likud en las
últimas cuatro elecciones el
estancamiento para formar un gobierno de
coalición se podría deber a esto
muchísimo le ha afectado porque hay una
cantidad de partidos políticos que
argumentan que no se pueden sentar en un
gobierno de coalición con una persona
que está en proceso judicial tengamos en
cuenta que se habla mucho de la ley
francesa se habla que el primer ministro
debía poder gozar de una especie de
inmunidad hasta que termine su cadencia
por el momento no existe tal cosa aquí
por lo tanto no ha pasado nunca que un
primer ministro esté en proceso judicial
durante sus funciones ahora gabriel en
ese sentido el presidente israelí está
en ese momento en consulta con varios
partidos para ver posibles alianzas y
coaliciones gobernantes cuál es la que
más se perfila para gobernar
es muy complicado decirlo porque tenemos
tres escenarios el más probable y es que
los partidos que no están a favor del
metal ya no logren algún tipo de acuerdo
de rotación
y logren conformar gobierno igual no es
una gran probabilidad la segunda que le
tenía un logre conformar un gobierno
sólido con la ortodoxia judía y con el
apoyo compartido árabe desde afuera del
gobierno y la tercera y creo yo que es
la más probable es que vayamos a una
quinta elección eso le quería decir de
no llegar entonces a ninguna alianza
gobernante podríamos estar entonces como
usted lo dice a las puertas de unas
quintas elecciones y hasta cuándo
podemos ver entonces este estancamiento
de la formación de un ejecutivo
la bolsa de cuál es el chiste más famoso
en estos días es que las próximas
elecciones
tienes que regresamos entonces ya van a
colocar dos urnas para que ya pongas tu
voto por la quinta elección y por la
sexta elección
gabriel entonces esperemos a ver qué
pasa si estamos a las puertas con usted
no dice de unas quintas elecciones y
también posiblemente de una sexta
gracias por estar aquí con nosotros en
france 24 que tengo usted un feliz resto
día en jerusalén